du béton de l'acier et de la viande
cette exposition montre la vision de la
prison par Nicolas dobane le plasticien
est attiré voire obsédé par le milieu
carcéral depuis 10 ans il aborde ce
thème dans son art mon travail en
général questionne
euh tout ce qui est afféré autour
de la liberté l'enfermement la
contrainte la question de l'enfermement
en prison elle est superposable à des
tas de gens qui par exemple sentent
qu'ils sont pas dans le bon travail
sont pas dans la bonne famille mariés à
la bonne personne et cetera voilà c'est
ça qui qui m'intéresse ça ça devient
très universel son exposition à la
maréchalerie renouvelle la peinture
d'histoire c'est la rétention des
détenus qui est raconté à travers la
matière ce dispositif présente
lesestigmat de l'incarcération et nous
font partager l'intimité de du vécu et
de de ces
détenus vous verrez un certain nombre de
graffiti sur sur ces plaques d'acier des
dessins des inscriptions des écrits un
comptage de calendrier il y a à certains
endroits des des traces de cou peut-être
de chaises ou de pieds là vous voyez que
la plaque d'acier est en creux et comme
si quelqu'un avait tapé là-haut c'est
peut-être des pieds ou des voilà du
mobilier qui a été tapé la deuxième
œuvre présentait mauvais œil le résultat
d'une performance l'artiste sur
plusieurs jours a réduit en poussière le
B des portes de prison l'exposition est
gratuite et pour tous les publics des
médiateurs vous accueillent pendant la
visite et des activités sont prévues
tous les samedi matin pour les plus
petits quand les enfants touchent à
cette matière de gravure et qui viennent
enlever et cetera ils se disent voilà
c'est plus ou moins difficile sur un
morceau de Lino de papier de moquette ou
de quoi que ce soit et en fait
d'imaginer ensuite l'artiste qui doit
pendant quelques heures entamer la
matière de l'acier il se projette en
mlant peinture histoire et conditions
humaines cette exposition est pour
Nicolas dobane un moment marquant dans
sa
carrière